what's up guys bang-bang lunch money
time while while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us is just trying to
get our lunch money right I am here with
the beautiful and intelligent plain of
Mara Nova if I had a guy coast he would
be beautiful and intelligent as well but
this one is my co-host are you beautiful
intelligent no come on ugly and dumb
that's fine in care which mean his real
don't hide here
don't forget less money is now sponsored
by black fine they gave me new things to
say pay attention black fire is running
the largest promotion they have ever had
so you're gonna want to pay attention to
this block 5 is now the easiest way to
earn up to eight point six percent APY
on your crypto and right now today
through July 18th if you go and you sign
up and fund an account they will give
you double interest bonus if you fund
the account before July 18th that's
right
so for the month of August you're
earning twice as much as you normally
would normally it's eight point six
percent APY that means I'm no
mathematician it'll be more than 17% ap
watt for the month of August I think
it's only one month of this double bonus
but if you go and you open an account on
block by deposit money you earn a double
interest bonus all you have to do is use
the code to X the number to the letter X
cuz to X double get it ha to X when
you're signing up and you will get the
double interest bonus block Viacom slash
lunch money go get money and get paid
speaking of getting paid Palantir is
going public what's going on with them
mr. Polina sorry I kind of forgot about
the joke so I just had to find one real
fast but jokes doesn't my skin look
great I'm turning it into a secret of
big data analytics startup Palantir
which was co-founded by Peter teal said
that it has confidentially
paperwork with the US SEC to go public
okay hold on a second first of all can
we can't even call pound here a start-up
is this like the oldest unicorn out
there I was founded in 2004 why haven't
they gone public yet
timeout Reid and what and are they even
secretive they're going public how are
they secretive no no it's not we know
exactly what they did
no we do not you do not yes I do they
win government contracts exactly do you
know what's in those government
contracts yes they're public the
government contracts are public people
just like to describe it as secretive
because they work with the government
doing like intelligence based stuff but
the government contracts are clearly
public and know they would they are not
the oldest unicorn in the private market
well so for example I know SpaceX was
founded I think in 2002 there private
that's one example but yep and Palantir
has it's like I know what $20 SpaceX ISM
backed by venture capital is it by who
who a lot they've raised a lot of money
from VCS information on there all right
so what do we think happens to Palantir
and why are they going public I don't
know why they're going public I do it
did not say when it plans to go public
nor do to provide other information such
as how many shares it would potentially
seller share I guess that that's the
part of confidential confidential Inc
filing for going public also that makes
it secretive sorry No then you'd have to
say everybody's secret if it doesn't
compound Sears probably going public
because if you can get into the public
markets right now between now and the
election I expect asset prices will
continue to get pumped to the sky and so
you can get into the public markets
you're gonna get incredible acquittee
you're gonna get an absolute explosion
on the stock price for example I was
talking with somebody yesterday we were
talking about the lemonade IPO lemonade
in 2018 did 20 million dollars in
revenue lost 50 in 2019 they did 65
million
in revenue so they tripled in revenue
but they lost a hundred million dollars
so they actually lost more money than
they were in the gamed in revenue and
the stock is now trading at a four
billion dollar valuation which means
that it's almost forty times revenue
when you have a market like that
everyone wants to get into public
markets because they Mesa are gonna get
such a inflated valuation and if they
can get out into that public market
stock price takes off then people can
sell and they can actually convert their
shares into cash
that's how public markets work so one
report estimates that the company's
valuation hovers at 26 billion billion
all right what's going on pvp loans PPP
not to be so confused the Trump
administration know me after the
Democrats kind of pushed them to do this
they released a list of companies that
received the most money from the small
business bailout loans so all the
companies that aren't really small
businesses that got that PPP money
you're out there however there have for
example the list said that bird received
pvp money then bird came and said no we
did it we filled out the application
with city but then we decided not to
follow through so and then sitting have
to come out and confirm that they didn't
so basically I think an audit will have
to be conducted okay back on through
people who forget payroll protection
program the whole idea of this was give
money to people give loans to companies
to help them protect jobs that was the
idea behind him the two issues that come
up is one do these companies actually
need the money or are they just taking
it because it's low-cost capital and to
to blame this point who got the money
there was no transparency or
accountability and so what you just
described to me is if that's an issue
like how many other errors are in the
database a lot you think yeah why
because I think why are you upset right
now no are you sure are you upset why
are you upset
oh we can just talk about it right now
no so basically I think there's a number
of people who got it who are like for
example why is Transportation Secretary
of Leaning Chows family business getting
alone alright so this was back up for a
second oh my god
not because we're going down the
slippery slope that we don't want to go
down just because oh this business is
run by a family that that has an
individual that works in the government
who is a number of news organizations
receive PPP loans Forbes The Washington
Times fortune The Washingtonian The
Daily Caller like I'm not exactly sure
these are small businesses it's not just
for small businesses okay well the Small
Business Administration issued this but
again the Small Business Administration
may have issued it but the money is not
just for small businesses okay so what
were we saying how there was gonna be a
list that came out and if you were on it
kind of sucks for you well for sure
eventually there's gonna be
accountability but in my opinion I'm not
mad that people went and applied for
loans what I get mad about is that there
are people who are frankly just abusing
the system so so for example if you're a
business that is a venture capital firm
or I saw somewhere in one of the filings
there's a firm in Atlanta that does
capital placement they have three
employees three they got five to ten
million dollar loan now the reason why
is I feel like they're abusing the
system is because they are unaffected by
kovat now they will argue oh well we
can't go meet our clients no you're not
because most of the revenue of asset
management firms for example is tied to
ask this under management it's not tied
to anything else so for example our
business revenue didn't change there's
no change in revenue because of Kovan or
not coded because in an asset management
business the assets that you manage you
take a fee on top of them so if your
adventure capital fund same thing if
you're a private equity fund same thing
so why are you going and getting a loan
that's supposed to only be given
tality was we are just we're just gonna
apply for it and see if we get it but
that's kind of the point is one of the
stipulations was that you had to sign
and legally like agreed to the fact that
I need this money because my business is
being hurt by Kovan and so my question
becomes what's the punishment if people
sign that piece of paper and said I'm
applying for this money because my
business is detrimental II hurt by
covent and it's not what do we do I
don't think all right who did online
grocery who didn't the Trump
administration whoever issued that the
loans us online grocery sales hit record
7.2 billion in June so people are
shopping online for groceries as we see
in our hallway of our building
people are getting their groceries
delivered and wiping them down in the
hallway before they enter their home
it's kind of here is it are we are we
violating health guidance by not wiping
down our groceries I don't know is that
in the health guidance I don't know
I oughta mately I mean this makes a ton
of sense right people are realizing
things like core real estate what's some
of the best real estate being anchored
by grocery stores grocery stores now we
know our pandemic proof because they're
always going to be held open though will
never shut down the grocery store and so
all of a sudden you're gonna see a
massive surge for people that wanted to
buy real estate tied to grocery stores
online the same thing what's some of the
best online businesses to be invested in
right now obviously food delivery
supermarkets all that kind of stuff and
so I think that this is just a natural
kind of trend along with the explosion
in food deliveries obviously online
grocery shopping is basically just food
delivery of a different country we think
it's the cart is doing really well I
think anyone that is involved in the
logistics of getting food to people is
gonna do really really well right now
right I mean there's less plaintiffs
said there's literally people in our
hallway who when they get their
groceries delivered they then sit in the
hallway and take wipes and wipe down all
the food your decide no no Sri explosion
if you're not willing to if you're going
that far to wipe down your groceries
you're definitely not gonna go to the
grocery store yeah right so like you're
so germaphobic in the sense of you're
taking it so so seriously that you
probably switch from maybe you had never
ordered groceries before or less than
10% of your grocery purchases were
online to now you're going 90 plus
percent of food ordering being online
for groceries yeah it's just a massive
movement of the wallet right yeah agree
yes how come we've never ordered
groceries online we have once you don't
remember because I order them
tik-tok the United States is looking at
banning tik-tok and others Chinese
social media apps
Pompeyo said the Secretary of State Mike
Pompeo said that the u.s. look at our
band like I don't believe him they've
said this for two years now I don't
really I don't really care nor believe
him a little low energy today but it's
about to get real hot here's about me
some hot takes why don't you believe
because he's been seeing that since 2017
no yes the government has not been
saying yes no people have been pushing
and in trying to pressure the government
but the government has not been saying
that okay this is one of the first times
ever the government has come out and
said they're looking at doing this okay
well by the way sure is working by the
way a couple of important facts here US
military band tik-tok US military
personnel cannot use tik-tok second
india just ban 58 Chinese mobile apps
including tic-tock tic-tock lost 200
million users overnight because China
banned it
I actually believe the u.s. is going to
ban tik-tok they're going to be forced
to do it it's the same thing like with
Huawei where they declared literally
they declared Huawei technology and
products to be a national security
threat they're gonna do the same thing
here here's what tic-tock tic-tock
spokesperson said tik-tok is led by an
american CEO with hundreds of employees
and key leaders across safety security
products and public policy here in the
US we have no higher priority in
promoting a safe and secure app
experience for our users
we have never provided user data to the
Chinese government nor would we do so
fast
is that a blatant lie
flag penalty let me teach you guys a
trick ready what they said is we've
never given them data what they didn't
say was we don't work with the Chinese
government we don't listen to the
Chinese government didn't say any of
that perfect example
tick tock is pulling out of Hong Kong
why are they doing that oh I don't know
maybe because Hong Kong just lost its
sovereignty is this okay so very
interesting why would the Chinese
government want all these teenagers data
because think of it like data collection
and surveillance right I want as much
data as possible that I can put through
all of my models and machines and all
this kind of spam and so for example
Huawei the reason why is a security
threat is if all of a sudden the world
ran on infrastructure for communications
both internet and 5g talking on the
phone all that stuff and they were able
at any point to grab that data they
basically could spy on your emails on
your phone calls on all that kind of
stuff right they could also an attendant
crisis deny you service right so hey all
the sudden they're literally a violent
war breaks out you go to pick up the
phone the phone doesn't work right
that's wall way tick tock
there's this great tweet I wrote about
this today that is why I have so much
detailed thoughts on it but there's this
engineer who reverse engineered
tick-tock and was able to see what's all
the data they're collecting on you it is
incredible amount of data everything
from the device you're using the
software your GPS location all of that
kind of stuff
and so it is much more egregious and
data collection than other social media
apps and the question becomes why do
they want all that data what are they
doing with that data that they need it
are they gonna turn it over to the
Chinese government
do you want your just it seems so
innocent tik-tok videos you know people
dancing can be used like a secret it's
not what it's not the content I know
it's all the metadata so there's a thing
where if you have to talk on your phone
they can tell all the other apps you've
downloaded again sounds like it's
that big of a deal except for of all of
a sudden you've got something an
application let's say something as
simple as you've got health information
right and they can start to pull all
this information about you and the
question is not so much
oh we know what they're doing with it
it's just the fact that do you want the
Chinese Communist Party to have your
data that's what Washington is saying so
I think it's gonna end up getting good
do you think it's not and by getting
banned you mean they're gonna just get
it off the Apple store and so I don't
think that the US government well maybe
they could but it would be pretty
unprecedented I think Apple would have
to choose to take it out of the App
Store Google could do it in some places
but other places they couldn't I think
what's more likely is that the US
government will come out and they will
outlaw American music from using it you
know I feel like that's just gonna you
know make it even more popular that the
government banned an app now you don't
think so how is it how your if you post
it on the internet they're gonna see it
yeah but who's gonna know what my
username was all they had to do is look
on the geolocation basis and say send me
all what they do that national security
they literally steal all your other data
the US government has an electronic
surveillance on you for national
security while we be nervous our friend
Jenna who watches lunch money said that
she deleted tik-tok for this exact
reason shout out Jenna she's offering
alright alright what's going on at
Harvard this were the real heartaches
come get your fire extinguishers bad I'm
annoyed by it too we're all we're all in
this together we're gonna suffer
together Nina is in a real bad mood
today she's ready to murder me she's
laughing because it's true I'm assuming
that I might not be here tomorrow guys
she may murder me after this let's back
up a little bit Harvard now you know
exactly you know exactly
[Music]
she acts like I don't know what I'm
doing
I know exactly what I'm doing let's go
roll the tape roll the table ever
comments and realizes exactly when I got
upset I know when you got up so the
second time I said let's back up three
separate times three times go back
you'll see all the tape
let's go is called hard after I got a
new one this is not a relationship show
what Harvard will hold all undergraduate
classes online this fall and invite only
40% of students to campus here's the
catch though if you go back to campus
most likely if you're a freshman that's
who they're letting come back you have
to sit in your dorm and still take
online classes it's like the dumbest
thing I've ever heard the virus exposed
all the shams and and on top of it you
want to back up a little bit true on top
of it if you are a student studying in
the US but you're from another country
go into Harvard I says that you have to
go back to your country and take the
online classes unless if you're on a
student visa if you're on a student visa
or if you don't want to do that you
could transfer away from Harvard and
stay in the u.s. I think carbons gonna
lose a lot of international students I
think that higher education the writing
is on the wall I don't know if it's in
one year five years or ten years the
gigs up the gig is up by the way if
you're literally so dumb that you need
to take on $50,000 of debt every year to
go to a school that you can literally
use the internet Google and I can show
you most of the Harvard classes for free
on the internet okay to play devil's
advocate
good don't you think that there is value
in studying something from a specific
Harvard professor than just googling or
like youtubing videos on the subject you
can read most of what they've written
you can listen to podcast they've been
on you can watch YouTube videos all the
information is there you just gotta be
motivated to do it so one of the
problems is that people sitting at home
self studying if you will they're not
gonna do it the second thing is there's
an argument that peep
aren't actually going to Harvard for the
education but going they're going for
the name recognition and then the
personal network but if everyone's
sitting at home did you really get the
personal network if it's just done
online you could do this stuff on
Twitter like Twitter actually has a
better graph a social graph then Harvard
students sitting at home and yes right
now
Harvard carries weight in terms of the
name but if all of a sudden people rose
wait a second Harper's just online it's
a little just kids sitting at home
online it will lose some of its kind of
you know power and on top of that I have
yet to meet somebody who I'm like mad
they went to Harvard like I should hire
that person I the world is moving to
what can you do not what have you done
in the past I agree with that also
this is ridiculous if you decide to go
live on campus and Harvard students will
be required to wear masks observe social
distancing protocols in submit to Coba
19 tests every three days like so just
just make it like just ban everybody
don't make this ridiculous
whatever they can eat outside or they
can bring their food back to their
bedrooms yeah why would you pay to go to
sit in a dorm room that's as big as your
bathroom well well if you're not paying
today and it gets you out of your
parents house I could think of a lot of
reasons why I would leave and go to the
campus if you're not meaning if you've
got a scholarship you've taken on debt
what you mean like it's not coming out
of your pocket right now today and it
gets me out of my parents house and I'm
a seventeen year old kid who's gonna
give you a raise II you would do
covetous every few days pick that thing
up your nose
I mean how like how strict are they
gonna be about it I feel like British
Church you ever been to a college campus
they literally came and figure out which
kids are drinking in their dorm rooms or
not are they really gonna be able to
keep track we're gonna line you up like
in a Chinese communist camp and say okay
walk down and okay keep walking and do
everybody into practiced on me sorry
alright fun one shot short shorts Tesla
having a great year the stock is up 200
percent in 2020 its market value now
exceeds every other
our maker on the planet as well as
Disney and coke those are not car makers
CEO Elon Musk is now trying to prove the
haters wrong by selling red satin short
shorts that sold out in minutes on the
website and they are a jab at the
investors who shorted the company I mean
this was like literal this was like the
easiest call of all time why would you
ever short the company that makes the
best electric vehicle in the world
because people thought it was like a
fraud people are idiots literally people
are idiots thinking that Tesla is a
fraud in Musk tweeted we'll send some to
the short seller enrichment commission
to comfort them through these difficult
times
that's a job at the SEC yeah because he
basically claims that the SEC is
constantly going after people on because
of the pressure the short seller
community so people so what a lot of
people forget is that you can actually
go ahead put a short on a company right
like say that that you're betting at the
company stocks and go down and then you
can run out and yell and scream that the
company's a fraud and there's certain
people who that's literally their
business model they discover the fraud
they put the short on then they kind of
publicize the fraud they make a lot of
money doing it other people then run to
the SEC and say hey that companies for
FRA cubbies and product companies and
fraud now there's two arguments here one
is short sales are actually healthy for
the market right there the balance on
just everyone who's long and - is
actually short sellers are probably able
to find frauds better than the SEC is
right out of the gate because they have
a financial interest to do so so if you
look at something like wire card in
Germany shorts I've been yelling about
that one for the year and a half so why
aren't we listening to them on Tesla
which was the most shorted stock ever
because what everyone is looking at with
Tesla is if you look at this short
sellers they yell and scream about
things like Elon Musk has no ethics he
said they were gonna deliver fifty
thousand cars they only delivered 42,000
like that's not a fraud right instead
what it is is they miss the deadline
they missed a milestone whatever
and there's time but okay okay so he's
ambitious right and he he believes they
can get things done faster and bigger on
a timeline but ends up being unrealistic
or that they don't hit there's other
times though where he says something and
they do exceed it right and so it ends
up becoming this thing where like
there's a balance between if you're
hitting a hundred percent of your goals
your goals aren't big enough right as is
my belief now the balance is in the
public markets you got to be careful
about how you say it what you say right
and so when he does it he's probably
operating on the edge of what's
acceptable what's not acceptable but at
the end of the day they ended up
slapping him on the wrist when he
stepped over the line so when he said
he's taken the company private for 20
SEC fine I'm like so that the system
kind of works but again why would you
bet against the company that has built
the best electric vehicle in the market
and also has the best technology from
what we can tell so far when it comes to
electric batteries why bet against that
it's so short-sighted yeah you know what
happened massive short squeeze a year
ago the stock was trading at $230 is now
trading it over $1300 so the people who
shorted it the rest right now most of
them probably closed out their shorts
and when as they were closing the shorts
that's why it really exploded up because
there's lowered a short squeeze but look
at the end of the day long Elon Musk I
will always bet on the founders and the
innovators over betting on the short
sellers because one has history at their
back which is over time innovation loads
that's it for much money today guys wait
no it's not what about my joke oh well
if you're gonna have a piss-poor
attitude on the show are we friends
again I don't know we have lipstick on
your teeth hey fellas I'll pay for that
one later yeah let's go what's your joke
come on don't look you literally she by
the way I just looked at her screen
she's funny jokes like what kind of
shoes
burglars where what type of shoes do
burglars where uh what type of shoes do
burglars wear burglars what is it
Berkeley's burglars burglars
burglars what type of shoes do they wear
they wear I don't know what sneakers
it's not bad that's not bad I think
sneakers yeah cuz they're sneaky ya know
everyone knows white-collar criminals
don't sneak they wear New Balances know
they wear loafers with no socks anyway
and walk down alright alright guys
that's it for lunch money god you close
this out there that's it for today we're
gonna leave with the beautiful and
annoying Anthony Vaughn play on oh and
see you next time
am I allowed back on the show tomorrow
we'll see okay bye guys bang-bang hope
you guys enjoyed this episode of lunch
money as much as we did
don't forget lunch money's now sponsored
by block v so go check them out there's
a link in the description that you can
click on I'm an investor a user and a
huge fan what you're a bigger fan of
block fire than you are of me block wise
my second favorite thing in the world
behind polina
they've got three products they can give
you a US dollar loan you can earn up to
eight point six percent interest on an
interest-bearing account or you can buy
and sell crypto currencies on their
crypto exchange I personally use the
interest-bearing account there's not
very many places where you'll find up to
eight point six percent interest on a
deposit in an interest-bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but eight point six percent
it's pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks that block by subscribe to our
channel like the video annoy playing in
the comment and we'll see you guys
tomorrow and be kind to your friends